cool all right so let's get started uh
we have Jonathan and L yeah uh talking
about forecasting with classical and
machine learning methods using SK time
is it SK time SK time SK
time all right hey uh good morning
everyone uh pleasure pleasure being here
and having all of you uh wonderful
people here in the audience uh super
psyched to be giving this talk so yeah
uh luuka and I uh we are contributors
and then members of the SK time
organization which we'll talk about
later um but the purpose of this talk
right is to really kind of go through um
both from just a um you know educational
perspective uh how to combine uh
statistical and machine learning methods
for forecasting which is I think kind of
an interesting problem if anyone's
familiar with the space and then also uh
introduce you all's not familiar with it
uh the actual SK time package and so how
it actually makes these workflows uh a
lot more simplified and easier to
use all right
so all right so just in case uh we're
going to start off with just a couple of
definitions here in case people are new
to this domain I imagine quite a few of
you probably do forecasting at your job
and so maybe you're up to dat with the
latest research that's great but in case
uh we have people who are just getting
introduced to this uh topic for the
first time all right so
forecasting uh broadly speaking is using
uh past observations to predict the
future that are sequenced by time okay
meaning uh your data has a particular
time index and then each one of those
index points you have a particular
observation and so you actually want to
use the patterns uh from previous time
based observations to extrapolate what's
going to be happening in the future okay
so it is a particular sort of learning
task which has unique properties to it
as we'll see in the future
okay um so generally speaking uh the
problem statement we're going to talk
about here okay um so so forecasting is
actually a very important component of
data science uh lots of companies
actually would benefit from from good
forecasting uh and then it's also an
area where machine learning will not
necessarily uh improve your results uh
if you're not aware of certain types of
details all right so um as we'll see
here uh getting state-of-the-art and
forecasting with ML is actually kind of
difficult and it's actually probably
easier to do more harm than good if
you're not careful uh it's also Al true
the time series ecosystem in Python uh
for the most part is fairly fragmented
okay uh sklearn doesn't really touch
time series models uh very very much
actually hardly at all um you know stats
models API is a little rigid and then uh
just the different components of Time
series modeling uh typically kind of
exist in sort of like this sort of
fragmented ecosystem that's not really
unified and so uh usually uh time series
modeling in Python is substandard uh
compared to R particularly if you're
you're sticking with kind of the the
tried and true classical techniques so
uh we're going to talk about how SK time
uh in addition kind of talking about how
to actually do forecasting and some some
best tips and practices uh we actually
want to learn about how SK time is going
to help us reconcile these problems all
right so we'll go over a few definitions
to begin with um then we'll kind of talk
about uh classical and then machine
learning methods uh their properties and
how they compare to one another we're
going to kind of cover like the the
landscape in about 2 or 3 minutes there
uh we're going to talk about common
steps you have to take when doing time
series modeling uh so there are sort of
definite tasks you have to be able to
complete to do it correctly and we'll
walk through some examples to kind of
see what that looks like and then
finally uh we're going to work through a
few example use cases so like if you
want to use deep learning uh if you have
hierarchical data and you need to you
know forecast a bunch of Time series
simultaneously um these are all very
very common issues you typically have to
deal with and so we're going use esate
time to demonstrate that uh so hopefully
that sounds like a good time and
everyone's looking forward to the next
35 minutes all right okay so we talked
about
forecasting uh so time series data okay
it's probably going to be best I think
just to take a look at a picture of it
so we'll go to the next slide here all
right there are different versions of
Time series data but in its simplest
form you can see what it is right over
here so the idea is you have
observations recorded at a single time
Point like over here and then uh usually
the index either explicitly or
implicitly uh is basically uh demarcated
by a time stamp like this right so you
have date observation date observation
date observation okay um this by itself
you this is just a panda Series so it
might not really look all that
remarkable uh but time series data has
some remarkable properties to it uh that
you really need to understand if you
want to be able to effectively uh do
forecasting okay uh the big thing is uh
time series data has a lot of
autocorrelation which means if you're
observing some kind of trend over time
uh a data point is going to be much more
similar to its nearest data points than
to one's previously far back in the past
most of the time okay uh this actually
violates a few assumptions of most ml
models which typically assume uh that
your data is a particular sample is
basically effectively random and it's
not really connected to other samples in
your data set so we're going to
visualize this uh to kind of make sure
we can kind of uh get some intuition for
how this works so this is a fairly
generic looking time series I think it
represents shampoo sales month by month
but it doesn't really matter okay uh
like a lot of Time series you can see
here there's a trend right it's kind of
going up over time uh it's a little bit
random and sarcastic stochastic if you
will you know they kind of bounce around
a little bit uh but if you look over
here at this data point right uh this
data point is more closely associated
with its nearest data points over here
than with the ones that you see over
here they're closer together right so
that's basically what autocorrelation is
and so if you wanted to sort of
graphically uh visualize uh how these
values are related to one
another uh let's take a
look at an autocorrelation plot okay uh
if there are any statisticians in the
audience I will point out you would
normally difference the time series
before we look at this this plot R over
here I understand that but this is just
for explanation purposes to to kind of
communicate a few points okay so what
we're seeing here
right uh every single value in the time
series correlates with itself perfectly
okay but you look at this these next
points right over here uh we can see
these values that are around 7 or 75 uh
the way you can interpret that
right is if you look at this point right
and you compare compared to this one or
if you look at this point compared to
this one or this point compared to the
one right before it that usually means
there's a 70% correlation that an
observation has with his previous value
okay uh meaning any particular value is
not all that
independent and so if you actually look
over these different lags okay you can
see here uh the correlation just kind of
gradually decays over time and then
eventually goes negative all right but
the take on point here is in Time series
data one particular observation is
usually closely associated with
observations that come before it so if
you actually have a sample from your
data set it's not like you're just kind
of drawing a random card from a
deck this next plot if you Shuffle the
same time series okay and then redo the
same plot uh you'll see something like
this and you can see here uh the
correlations in the data then uh
basically go down drastically so the
take on point right is that time series
data has a very particular temporal
structure to it and so that has
important implications for how you can
go ahead and model
it right and so normally uh most ML and
learning methods are built on this
assumption that your data is IID uh
which stands for you know uh
independently and identically
distributed uh but time series data is
not
IID and so in order to deal uh with the
properties of Time series data uh there
are a number of classical techniques
that have been around for a long time
that deal with the sequential nature of
time data very explicitly so a few of
these are exponential smoothing ARA and
Theta if you're familiar with the time
series literature there's a few others
as well but broadly speaking they all
exist uh specifically to handle the
sequential structure of time based data
and again this is something that machine
learning models out of the box don't
necessarily
do okay so
for most of the history of time theories
modeling uh the classical models have
been uh fairly standard and then even
today uh in a lot of problems machine
learning models will actually
underperform classical
models all right and so the basic reason
why uh is because autocorrelation if you
have that in your data uh basically
reduces the effect of sample size of the
actual samples you can go ahead and
learn from so rough speaking the more
autocorrelated your data is um the less
the less important more distant data
points actually
are and of course your machine learning
and deep learning models benefit from
loss of training data right uh but the
meaningful training data in your actual
data set's going to go down the more
autocorrelation that you have so
therefore it's kind of hard to really
reap the benefits of uh you know more
contemporary machine learning methods uh
if you're dealing with time series data
that's kind of the the underlying theory
behind it
and if you want an example of this
there's something called the monach
forecasting repository uh it is kind of
something similar to maybe like the
image net for for time series models and
forecasting it's a collection of a few
dozen different data sets and so what
they
do is they have uh an ongoing update uh
for different data sets and different
models and then their current uh
state-of-the-art and so if you look
through this you can see on the left
hand side
you have very very old school time
series techniques and as you go across
the right hand side over here you get to
more and more modern and contemporary
architectures okay uh the highlights are
in Black uh but one of the take on
points should be um you know uh
classical models on a lot of data sets
uh actually still outperform uh the
latest deep learning models uh so kind
of the the take on point is that machine
learning is not necessarily a free lunch
when it comes to time series forecasting
and so performance on a particular data
set is going to be very very contextual
so in some ways it's almost like the
exact opposite of NLP right we're like
for if you have a translation problem
you would just kind of automatically use
some kind of Transformer and not really
think twice about it um but that's not
true at all uh for for time serious
problems um clarification when you said
performance do you mean the speed in
which it runs or do you mean the
accuracy forecasting accuracy for yeah
forecasting accuracy yeah in fact uh I'm
pretty sure this I forget exactly what
this metric is but I think it's
something like root mean squ error or
something like that or mean absolute
error um it's also true uh you the Deep
learning models typically take longer to
to fit to obviously because they have
more parameters I think it probably goes
without saying you know but this is just
this is just
accuracy uh other
questions okay so yeah yeah moving on
right so
um uh so time series is a bit different
from a lot of other domains uh in in
data science um but at the same time uh
there is still a very strong push uh to
actually see if we can actually use
machine learning uh to better model time
series data okay so I think there are
four big reasons why okay uh you know
lots of time based data does have very
subtle idiosyncratic nonlinear patterns
and so obviously you know uh a high
parameter machine learning model is
going to do a better job of picking up
on that a lot of times if you actually
want to model time series dat
you don't just want to look at previous
values but you want to incorporate
external information as well right so if
you work in marketing uh you know you
might have like sales or promotions you
know there could be holidays uh so there
are a lot of kind of external company
based factors that you might actually
want to use when you're You're Building
forecasts and then uh machine learning
models are probably going to be better
to incorporate the information inside of
that than just a pure time series
model a big thing too right is uh lots
of Time series data sets today you're
not just modeling a single time series
but rather you know thousands or tens of
thousands or even Millions kind of
simultaneously at the same time and so
having like a a Time series model for
each one of those time series is
probably not very practical so having a
a master time series model that you can
use to kind of model all the time series
inside your organization is uh very very
appealing and then it's also been true
in the most recent forecasting
competitions uh the machine learning
methods are keep pulling away from the
pack and so uh we're continually getting
uh better and better improvements at the
very very top of the domain uh using
different combinations of machine
learning methods as opposed to time
series
methods okay quick show hands has
anybody heard of the M4 or M5
competitions couple of hands here okay
all right so I know a few of us are
familiar with them uh so these are
competitions that are held every couple
years um they used to determine
basically current benchmarks for
state-of-the-arts and uh the forecasting
domain uh they typically come with cash
prizes they're usually done over kagle
uh I think like the last one I think
there was $100,000 given out to the top
you know performance performers and
again uh people use like to use the M
competitions as kind of a way to
understand and discover kind of what
current best practices are and uh you
know what sorts of expectations you can
have for time service problems most
recent one uh was a bunch of retail data
from Walmart had over 42,000 time series
there were over you know 5,000
competitors and so basically if you
looked at the top 50 or top 100 uh
entrance they were almost all using some
combination of machine learning models
sometimes mixed with time series models
but it was clear uh ml models were
actually the best performing uh if you
actually looked at the top contestants
uh the clear winner in terms of method
that gives you the best results probably
not too surprising uh was like GBM I
mean anyone who follows kle I mean lots
of G like T's use you like GBM but the
point is um even for for a Time series
problem uh if you actually have the
correct approach a machine learning
model typically can give you better
results all right so we're going to talk
a little more about the this last M5
competition just to kind of give us a
feel for what sort of the current
president is you know for um for best
results right so uh light GBM was the
most common uh you know technique used
over 5,000 different teams
uh worth pointing out though so this The
Benchmark that the competition used was
called
esbu so what this is is a technique that
will algorithmically determine uh what
sort of exponential smoothing model to
use and then use an exponential
smoothing model for each individual time
series so essentially there was sort of
this this classical time series
Benchmark and then out of the you know
5,000 over 5,000 teams uh only 7 and a
half% of them were actually able to beat
the time series benchmark so it's kind
of the case where machine learning uh
can clearly give you state-of-the-art uh
but it's not necessarily going to be um
this really straight forward Affair to
beat you know a a decently fitted uh
time series model that's you know well
suited to the problem uh something I
thought was actually kind of fascinating
is uh over half the contestants couldn't
actually beat the naive Baseline which
means if your model is just predicting
the last value you know you calculate
the root mean squar error about half the
submissions actually couldn't be Val as
well so just to kind of reinforce the
point right um so if you're dealing with
time series problems uh you definitely
have this issue where the best
performing model is not going to be
clear at all
beforehand okay also in terms of how
well these uh you know these contestants
actually did so according to the esbu
Benchmark okay the top 50 contestants
all beat up by at least 14% the number
one contestant beat up by
22.4% to give that a little bit of
context uh in the M4 competition No One
Beat The Benchmark by more than
10% okay so meaning um there is kind of
some separation now between the use of
machine learning and the use of Time
series models when it comes to getting
state-of-the-art now it's also true
though if you compare um you know this
number right over here with kind of a
traditional time series model I still
think in the big scheme of things it's
actually not that large like so for
example imagine if you're looking at a
translation problem and you compared
naive Bay you know to a Transformer I
think the difference would be so big
right you couldn't it wouldn't even be
worth comparing so the fact that like
we're still in the same neighborhood
here I think does also kind of um you
know Drive some the point that uh class
models and machine learning models are
pretty tightly coupled together compared
to other
domains all right so if you want to
compare these okay uh so time series
models uh typically have pretty tight
distributional assumptions machine
learning models not so much most time
series models have a small number of
parameters okay meaning uh they'll be a
couple of parameters for some of the
previous lags there might be something
for for seasonal term or Trend uh but
rarely do you have more than like a half
dozen parameters for for a Time series
model obviously uh big machine learning
models are you the exact opposite of
that uh time series models are typically
fit on an individual time series whereas
machine learning models are usually fit
globally on an entire data set which it
turns out is one of the important
benefits of using ml for lots of large
scale time series
problems okay and finally um time series
models are good at just kind of working
out of the box on your data usually for
machine learning models you're typically
going to have to do quite a bit of
feuture Engineering in order to get
desired
results okay so we're going to spend uh
the rest of this presentation actually
kind of walking through a few example
workflows and seeing how SK time kind of
gives you a nice unified toolbox for
combining these different methods and
then chaining all the intermediate steps
together okay so like I mentioned before
right uh one of the current problems if
you want to use time series models in
Python the ecosystem is fairly
fragmented and in homogeneous and so it
can be difficult uh combining all the
different tools together uh so SK
time
provides a unified
interface uh to basically unite uh the
time series ecosystem in Python so these
are just some examples stats models
profit TS learn PMD Arena uh all of
these are actually incorporated into SK
time and then you can go ahead and use
them for a variety of Time series
problems so it's basically designed to
be the only time series toolbox you'd
have to use in Python even if there are
these great new tools coming out
elsewhere Ware uh SK time has a really
strong interface to go ahead and just
incorporate them into an SK time
compatible estimator so that way you can
basically keep your same source
code all right so let's take a look and
just walk through a few simple examples
all right so we're going to look at our
toy data sets it's just a Time series
with some shampoo sales in
it all right so you can see this right
over here okay um this is the insample
data over here the add of sample data
you can see over here on the
right okay um so I'm assuming a lot of
people here are familiar with the theit
learn interface you import the model you
fit it you know and then you go ahead
and predict it afterwards um so SK time
is designed to basically take that same
interface and then apply it to time
series and then you can actually use any
sort of Time series model inside that
interface regardless of where it comes
from so in our next example here okay
what we're doing is we're importing an
auto AR Rema model this this is a very
old school time series technique okay
you can see here hopefully these steps
will look relatively familiar to you
right you're initializing it over
here um we're defining here this
variable as a forecast Horizon which
means we want to use this model to
predict six time steps into the future
okay that's a common issue deal with
forecasting a lot of times you might
have to make a forecast you know for the
next two weeks the next one month next
one year whatever and so uh a lot of
times you want to be able to Define how
far into the future you want to be able
to go ahead and predict so we're saying
this this means just predict uh six you
know six time steps into the future uh
and then you fit and then you predict
over here and then when you're done
right uh these are the model predictions
that you have over here as you can see
all right um the idea is this kind of
workflow should look pretty familiar
right because I'm sure most of us have
used SK learn at some point or another
so the idea is with SK
time this line that you started over
here we have Auto
ARA uh can basically be any sort of
model that you might want to go ahead
and use okay so they're classical time
series models you can use any SK learn
estimator and as LC is going to talk
about now they're also interfaces now
for p torch Transformers as well so if
you actually using the the latest and
deep learning uh you can basically
incorporate any of that and use it in
the same homogenous
workflow all right um if you're curious
or if you doubt you know kind of like
the the footprint of SK time uh it has a
few different uh functions you can use
to look up available estimators and so
if you can see here uh currently um
there are over 70 different time series
models that are directly built in uh to
SK time and it's also true uh you can
just it's compatible with any sort of SK
learn like interface so um even if it's
not listed here explicitly you can still
use it
okay um so we're we to spend the rest of
our time talking about now specifically
how to use machine learning for
forecasting problems right we talked
about before uh out of the box does not
necessarily give you good results it can
actually be quite difficult to be a good
time series Benchmark but it's also true
at the same time if you do want the best
results most of the time you're going to
have to use machine learning models to
go ahead and get that so the way uh
sklearn handles this is with something
called a reduction
uh which is essentially uh you know
being able to transform one sort of
problem into another so in the case of
uh reduction for for
forecasting right so this is time series
data over here on the
left right uh a machine learning model
isn't necessarily going to have
recognition of these previously
occurring values so what you actually
have to do is reconstruct your data so
that way it looks like this right so the
previous values exist as their own
independent columns and you use this as
input to basically go ahead and predict
what Y is all right so this is kind of
the reduction that's happening with SK
time and you can set this up uh with the
single function call so let's take a
look all right so what we're going to do
here we're using uh you know SK learns
version of light GBM the his gradient
boosting regressor uh same thing um any
estimator that has an sklearn interface
so it doesn't really matter where it
comes from uh you can initialize it the
same way and the way you can plug this
into a forecasting problem uh is with
the function make reduction all right so
this is the argument right over here and
then this right over here window length
where set equal to
16 refers
to how many of these columns you're
adding over here for previous values so
it is you can easily specify um you know
how many how many lag values you want to
use in the forecasting problem and you
can actually mix and match this with any
sort of you know estimator that you're
already used to use
it so if you go ahead and do this okay
uh same thing you can fit and predict I
take a look these are the outof Box
results um just using the eyeball test
you ought to be able to see the
predictions are not very good like
they're not really obviously
incorporating right the trend inside the
data and so same thing that's because um
you know uh machine learning models
aren't really well designed to handle
time series data out of the box so this
is kind of a common example so if you
have a trend a common issue with like a
tree based model is that um trees can
really only extrapolate to values that
they see inside the training set right
so that means if you have a trend your
out of sample data is probably going to
be larger than anything a tree based
model was seen so therefore it's not
really going to be able to go ahead and
extrapolate you know to like some if
you're you're trying to predict you know
100 samples into the future and you have
a trend in your data 100 time points out
is going to be larger than anything that
you see in your training data so
therefore you're not going to have great
results okay and you can see here right
out of the box the ARA model works
better than the hispan boosting
regressor um but the way you fix this
right is with some kind of
transformation steps so I think most of
us are used to pipelines in our models
so uh SK time includes a variety of
convenient time series Transformations
that are usually necessary for
pre-processing okay so in this case what
we're doing is we're going to difference
the data right which is where you
actually just subtract one value from
the previous one uh this is the way of D
trending it and so now if you look
now uh there's no obvious trend inside
the data which is really helpful because
that way if you're trying to predict
into the future the range of values in
your out of sample data is going to map
to what you have on the insample data
and so if you set up a
pipeline
which you can do with this one step
right over here right so the forecaster
and you can just go ahead and then take
the transformation step and multiply R
do the same thing the results are not
necessarily great but they're at least
coherent meaning the predictive values
are kind of aligned with the actual
level of the add of sample values over
here all right so that's a common
transformation step that you have to
take and then also SK time gives you a
very nice unified interface for
incorporating these into your modeling
steps uh same thing so SK learn does not
have great pre-processing for time
series models uh but this is really
easily built into the SK time
interface all right we're not going to
go over them now but things like
accounting for seasonality uh things
accounting for Trend um are all built
into the SK time interface and so adding
them to your modeling pipelines is very
simple and straightforward and it can
also definitely improve your
results okay so here's another example
I'm going to skip this the interest of
time but the idea is right uh you can
difference de season lines or do
anything else attach that to your your
estimator at the end and you can get
useful results out of the box pretty
quickly okay uh next thing we're talk
about is global forecasting okay so this
be a bunch of Time series models all at
the same time very common real world
scenario right uh so in Time series
models they're not always good at
dealing with this because you have to
fit a model individually for each time
series uh this is is a little bit
inconvenient and it's also the case that
if you have a global time series most of
the time uh the time series are going to
be
interrelated so here's an example a
global time series that's hierarchical
in nature so you have your product line
and the product group and different you
know time series inside those uh the
idea is most of the time uh time series
and the same product group might share
similarities so it make sense they can
learn from their joint patterns and so
you don't get that with just regular
time series modeling so this one of the
benefits of using machine learning
models because you actually have bigger
effective sample sizes so therefore the
enhanced pattern recognition of ml
begins to go ahead and kick
in all
right skip this real quick just the
interest of time all right so this is
kind of the difference between local and
Global forecasting right uh fitting an
individual model for each time series
versus fitting a single model for the
entire thing and so if you look at this
with SK
time let's take a look at some code uh
you can also do this easily as well so
the make reduction function we're
looking at right you pass in the
regressor uh you can also specify local
pulling or Global pulling and this
basically means do you want to fit an
individual model for each time series or
do you actually want to fit every single
time series as a global model itself um
and again for ML models this is
typically beneficial and as you can see
here if you do this um the results or
accuracy for the global model improves
significantly over the local one but we
still actually have not beat the uh you
know the time series Baseline again
which is
common so the next thing you typically
want to do right is actually build out
different features right that basically
capture different properties of a Time
series so same thing this is typically
very tedious takes lots of time um but
SK time has good uh sort of tooling to
do this for you
automatically so here what we're going
to do is calculate window features so
this is basically you know you take
Maybe you know the mean or the average
of standard deviation over the previous
end samples and so here you can specify
right uh what sort of statistical
measure you want to use the size of your
window and just with a typical
transformation step you can call fit
transform and you can basically turn
your time series data into something
like this all right where in addition to
having the previous lag values you also
have these windows statistics for each
of the individual time series and then
the benefit of this is is there can be a
lot of unique patterns in these features
that a typical time series model
wouldn't see so this is the skewness of
the individual time series right you
might look over here and see this right
this is very unusual there's a large
structural break for this time series uh
without this kind of feature processing
you wouldn't necessarily be able to
capture this and this is the exact sort
of thing a machine learning model could
potentially see very well all right so
same thing if we rerun through the same
steps okay we can now see uh the same
model with global pulling and the window
Transformations added in is now about
10% better than the auto ARA right this
is a simplified example but that's kind
of the idea behind the framework is you
can mix and match different methods and
processing steps and give yourself a
coherent uh time series
workflow um so with that being
said right uh deep models deep learning
models are all the rage so I'm going to
hand it off to Luca here uh to finish it
off to kind of talk about how you can
incorporate uh py toor into SK time
thanks Jonathan hi everyone I'm Luca I'm
a contributor at SK time and I've been
working on taking some high torch
networks and providing interfaces uh
with the SK time
Library so here's an example of one of
the models that is available to use as
you can see it follows the SK time
conventions uh SK learn conventions to
of uh find the model fit the model
predict the
model so yeah it's easy as that you know
we plot the predictions right
here this time series specifically was
multivariate and what's cool about this
forecaster is that it actually fitted a
specific layer for each time series and
you can see the out of sample
predictions on the right side
here so how does one actually uh choose
the right model to use uh for their use
case couple pointers uh first you'd want
to start with a very simple model uh
something like the either a naive
forecaster or one of the classical
models that Jonathan was talking about
and then you can start to add more
complexity uh ml models and deep
learning models can be
added and then throughout that process
you'll want
to get the accuracy of each model to
know if the complexity you're adding is
actually helping or
not now in this chart right here the
models at the top are going to be
simpler and then they're going to uh go
down as they get more complex and just
to reference the M5 competition that
Jonathan was talking about the um The
Benchmark was actually a classical model
so it's only this row two in this table
right here so everything beyond that is
going to have a greater
complexity right and then Jonathan also
had an example where he composed a
pipeline
um so kind of building off that last
point you can mix and match these models
to build a Transformer that can get high
accuracies all right and building off
that last Point again when you have a
long pipeline it can uh it can be
helpful to do ablation testing which
means you take away certain parts of the
pipeline you re-evaluate and you say
well if the performance stay the same
without this uh feature then clearly it
wasn't important I can get rid of it so
that's a good way to figure out what's
actually working and not in your
pipeline okay so just kind to summarize
Jonathan talked about uh time series
forecasting the basics some classical
models and we also talked about the
interaction between these classical
models and the newer ml models when
they're useful when they're not we also
talked about uh how you can go ahead and
Implement some of these
models
so it's kind of a final Point uh SK time
itself is supposed to be a very open
inclusive community whoever wants to
contribute can and we make it really
easy all you have to do is join the
Discord and we actually have weekly
meetings every Friday where if you want
you can uh you can show up talk to any
of the devs um get some one-on-one help
with whatever uh project that you're
working
on thank you for your
attention
use this to answer the questions and I
pass cool
yeah
any any
questions um what's dependency
management like for installing this um
well so the documentation on the website
you just use like a pip install SK time
and uh there's some other dependencies
there's like you know it's a unified
package so we pull in different things
so um there's something called all
x-rays you can uh install more things if
it's not working so you could so if I
was only interested in say like the
stats AMS back end you have that as like
an optional dependency are they W broken
out that way yeah yeah so yeah it would
it wouldn't break if you didn't have
like you know torch yeah yeah okay say
on that so there are heart dependencies
like nump
learn and then for the the zoo of other
stuff that you have you might actually
want to use those are soft dependencies
and then you can install those
specifically as you need them not as
just not as like one gigantic
package uh thank you for the talk this
is quite amazing um does SK time
currently provide um conformal
prediction TOS yes yeah yeah conformal
prediction is built into it and then for
anyone else who doesn't actually know
about that conformal prediction is a uh
statistical method
that actually gives you a statistical
guarantee for probability estimates and
so historically you know um
probabilistic forecasting was easily
more easily used with uh classical time
series models uh but with performal
prediction you can basically combine
probabilistic forecasting with machine
learning models to not just get better
Point estimates but to get better
confidence intervals as well and that's
just kind of context for the entire
audience but yeah it's actually built
into SK
time yeah thank you for the presentation
um I'm here sorry um so here we assume
that the time serice like explains
itself because we all the window
operations like SE operations but can we
have also like other drivers of the temp
series for example marketing expenses
and have like doing multi series
forecasting with this
framework yeah so um we it wasn't
actually due to time constraints it
wasn't covered in the examples here but
basically uh we basically only fit the
model models on why and just kind of
extrapolated from that but uh for any
sort of uh forecaster uh and then for
any kind of Time series uh SK time
compatible data set you can also pass in
a corresponding X as well with
independent predictors and then it would
actually just look at that automatically
into any final
questionid yeah yeah yeah where um
afterwards they should be able to be
disseminated if they're not there I I
can double check and
then okay I can look after that we'll
definitely show the slides I have a
question where does um uh pie torch fit
in like have you uh like uh have you
included something in SK time that uses
pie torch like an lstm model or some
that based model uh we don't have we
don't have lstm yet uh we're looking to
expand to you know some more uh
stateoftheart models like that but we
just have a like like pie torch back in
so the user doesn't actually have to
like really interact with the
tensors all right let's thank our
speaker